[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
Hello, and welcome to Google
Apps Unscripted.
I'm Eric Koleda and this
is my co-host, Kalyan.
KALYAN REDDY: Hey everyone.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
So this is our once a month,
approximately, show that we do
to answer your questions
for Google Apps Script.
So we're working on the
Developer Relations team.
So we're engineers that help
people use Apps Script, learn
about its features, help you
if you run into problems.
And this is a great chance, if
you're using Apps Script or
just getting started, to ask
us questions, talk about
something you're working
on, or talk about any
problems you have.
So we have to start off with a
little bit of news and kind of
like recent events in the
world of Apps Script.
And so yeah, we have a few
different things that came out
since our last episode, one of
which is a new blog post.
So this one is actually
really cool.
It's about the SETI Institute's
plans to name a
new moon of Pluto.
So they discovered
some new moons.
And I'm sure they had some sort
of very boring numerical
identifier, S/2001 13430.
KALYAN REDDY: That's
a great name.
ERIC KOLEDA: It rolls off
the tongue, right?
And so they wanted to open it
up to the world and get some
more interesting name
suggestions.
Did you submit any votes?
KALYAN REDDY: I actually
didn't.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, OK.
Well, I think it could
be too late now.
But obviously, there's a lot of
people who are interested
in this kind of stuff.
There's just people who are
interested in it in general.
There's people in the astronomy
field, a lot of
different opinions.
So they wanted to create some
way to conduct a very large
vote and also process
the data.
And I guess using some kind
of normal methods
really didn't work out.
And so they used Apps Script
as a way to help collect,
organize, and kind of collate
the data, as well as weed out
things that are known funny
names or bad names or kind of
get down to the meat of what
are some really good
suggestions.
KALYAN REDDY: Pretty cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
And so the blog post here goes
a little bit into how it was
done, why it was done.
And they said the results
are coming out soon.
I still don't know if it's
been announced yet.
I'll have to double check.
But at least the time of this
writing, I don't think they
announced the name.
But the final decision should
be coming out soon.
And I think Apps Script, we've
done our part to help make the
galaxy a better place.
KALYAN REDDY: And I think it
shows the simplicity and power
of Apps Script, because this
looks like a very professional
looking thing.
It's not like, here's this
crappy form, go ahead.
It looks really good.
All the results sets are
presented and collected
nicely, and it's very
easy to do.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I mean, I think this is one of
the places where Apps Script
really shines, which is you have
some sort of tasks that
you need to do, but it's
not permanent, right?
It's kind of a one time,
one off thing.
You're not going to go hire a
company to build you a complex
piece of software that
does your job.
And you want to do something
better than just send us an
email to this email address,
right, because who wants to
deal with that?
So it's right in that sweet spot
of lightweight, but still
powerful and still getting your
job accomplished in a
much more efficient way.
So do take a look.
And yeah, it's pretty cool.
Another piece of news is coming
up directly after this
broadcast, Arun Nagarajan, one
of our colleagues, he's over
in London right now.
And he's going to be doing
another Apps Script Google
Developers Live episode
called Script It!
With AdSense.
So it's possible to make
requests to AdSense API in
Apps Script, and you can do
some pretty neat things.
So he's going to be sitting down
with Nick Johnson, one of
our other engineers here at
Google, and kind of showing
off some of the cool
things you can do.
The Script It! series has
been really phenomenal.
I know he did one recently
on Android.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, that one's
really popular now.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
that one blew up.
KALYAN REDDY: I think
it's already up
to over 5,000 views.
So check that out.
I think there's a lot of good
information in that one.
More of like how to
very quickly get a
proof of concept going.
Someone posted as a comment
that they wanted to have
something to keep track of
their characters on a
"Dungeons and Dragons"
[? simulator. ?]
And they were like, this is
perfect for me, because it
doesn't require a whole lot of
back handling and setting all
that infrastructure up.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
KALYAN REDDY: They can get
going really quickly.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, yeah.
Arun is known for pulling off
some really awesome demos
during these.
And I think the killer one there
was having a spreadsheet
that when you update it, live
pushed the changes to an
Android app.
So yeah, it was pretty
awesome.
And I think you can expect just
as high quality demos
today in his AdSense
Script It! episode.
So do check that out directly
after this starting at noon
Eastern time.
All right, great.
KALYAN REDDY: Should we do--
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, want
to do release notes?
KALYAN REDDY: All right, there's
some good stuff.
ERIC KOLEDA: So if you're not
aware, we publish releases
kind of like somewhat
on a weekly basis.
And we capture some notes
about what's changed and
what's been fixed, what new
features are there.
So let's get it started.
What do we have on
April 1, Kalyan?
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see.
April 1, we fixed a
bunch of issues.
Well, first, I'll talk about the
new feature that we added.
We added new methods for
Sheet.hideSheet,
isSheetHidden, and showSheet.
So basically, if you do have
a sheet object that you've
gotten from your spreadsheet,
you can actually do operations
like hide or see what the status
is and control the
visibility of the individual
sheets.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, that's
pretty cool.
I know a lot of people use--
like when I have Apps Script, I
like to have a configuration
sheet or maybe a sheet that
stores some data, but they
don't want people mucking
around with it.
And so this allows you to
programmatically create a
sheet and then hide it so that
your script can bank on that,
knowing that it's probably not
going to be changed by the end
user accidentally.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
And it also eliminates that
extra human step of going in
in a minute and then hiding it
after your script runs through
and sets up the spreadsheets.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right, right.
Yeah, it's pretty nice.
KALYAN REDDY: Cool.
Let's see.
First fix, scripts that rely
on deleted libraries now
display a clear error message.
So this one, previously we had
a cryptic server, there has
been an error, server
error message.
And so that doesn't tell
you anything of
what the problem is.
The problem is that the script
was calling into some library
that wasn't there anymore.
And so we fixed it so that
now it says, hey,
your library is deleted.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
And I know the next one here
was a big issue for some
people, which is that the script
gallery would sometimes
return you an error when
you installed.
And I think it actually
still installed
correctly in those cases.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, that was
another instance where the
server error was displayed.
So people would oftentimes
refresh the page to reinstall
the script.
But the original one did
eventually get installed, so
they would have two copies.
And there was a lot of strange
interactions with that.
So we apologize if you had a lot
of users complaining about
problems with this.
But those concerns should
be alleviated now.
ERIC KOLEDA: Cool.
That's great.
KALYAN REDDY: That's fixed.
Let's see.
Event parameter for spreadsheet
onEdit function
now reports the affected range
correctly in a variety of
situations where range was
previously incorrect.
So this is kind of wordy, but
basically what it was is that
the event parameter, we often
call it E, it gives you the
range of the onEdit.
And oftentimes, that range was
just the top-left cell, or it
was some incorrect value that
didn't correspond to the
actual edited range.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
KALYAN REDDY: And it
wasn't uniform.
Oftentimes, it was giving
you the right answer,
but not all the time.
So now it should be
working uniformly.
Every time you call e.range
or whatever, the
eventparameter.range, you will
get the actual onEdit.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I think
this is a good case where
there are a lot of edge cases
when it comes to some of the
functionality that's in Apps
Script, because Google Sheets
provides so many different
ways to paste, so many
different combinations.
I remember, we were trying to
say, well, what if you take
two rows and paste it into
a range of four rows?
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: And so I think
although we strive for
perfection, there's probably
going to be these little tiny
inconsistencies that crop
up from time to time.
They are important to us, and
we do know it creates
frustration when you have
something that works 95% of
the time, and then in that rare
case, it doesn't work
quite right.
So do report those to us
by the Issue Tracker.
We'll hopefully get them into
these same release notes in
the near future as fixed.
And then on April 8, we did
some more exciting things.
The first one here, I know
something that you've looked a
lot into which is the
Document service.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, so the
Document service, I don't know
how many of you have used it
previously, but it can be a
little complicated.
There's a lot of
methods there.
Unfortunately, when you're
trying to programmatically
create a document, you do need
a lot of these methods.
And it can be a simple, clean
interface like some of our
other beans are.
But there were areas where there
was a lot of extra stuff
that you didn't need.
And one great example was all of
these .asSomething methods,
which is basically if you have
an object and it's like a
generic object, and you want
it converted into the exact
type of the object, then the
intention was you would do
generic object .asParagraph
or .asText or
whatever to get a sub-class.
And a lot of those times, we
were having these for things
that didn't make sense.
So like paragraph .asBodyelement
or something.
So that didn't need
to be there.
So we got rid of
a lot of those.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I mean, it
makes sense in the case where
you say, you know,
get me all of the
elements in this document.
Or search for some text and tell
me what element you found
it in, where you have an
element, but you don't know
what it is.
So you look at the type.
And then you want to get the
rest of your autocomplete.
So you do .as the real
type and then
keep going from there.
But once you know that it's a
paragraph, probably not going
to want to try to transform
into an image.
It's just not going to work.
.asImage didn't make sense.
So this was part of our
cleanup process.
We're looking at doing even more
clean up in this space,
but this was kind of like
our first step, kind
of just pare down.
Because we know that when you
can do a dot and you get an
autocomplete that's 10 miles
long, it makes programming
that much harder, because you're
like, oh, where do I
even start to find
my function?
KALYAN REDDY: And you're going
to continue seeing changes on
this in the next couple
of weeks.
We have pending changes
that are submitted.
They're just waiting
to be rolled out.
And then we're going to have it
be a nice, clean, efficient
bean after a couple of weeks.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's great.
And then the next one here is
just kind of a little bit of a
extra gloss on what we do,
which is we put some time
stamps in the log output.
So you can log to our log using
logger.log, which is
saying the word log a
lot in one sentence.
So you can just pick any value
you want, a variable, a
string, some numbers you have,
stick it into a log, so that
after you run, you can
see what things work.
It helps you do debugging.
It helps you figure out
if your script is
running as it should.
And so we've added just the
ability to automatically now
add time stamps to that log so
that you can see the progress
and see, wait, is this
the most recent run?
Or did I not run it correctly?
Or more of that information.
And then a couple
other bug fixes.
So these ones are about triggers
and about charts.
And you can click into the
issues if you actually want
more details.
There are just some small issues
that we ran across.
And we'll keep logging.
We try to be complete.
We want to make sure that every
time we close a bug, it
gets logged into the
release notes.
Occasionally, we miss them.
But for completeness sake,
you'll usually find most of
them in here.
KALYAN REDDY: And just a quick
note, the time stamp feature,
if someone was relying on the
output of the log to look a
certain way, you should try to
make your scripts in such a
way that that sort of thing
won't break them.
But if that is the case, then
there's definitely ways to
strip out that time stamp
portion and just return to the
log output.
Just use regular expressions,
if you know that.
Just pass that into a string
formatting type thing and then
you can get out the
original text.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I mean,
this is kind of a larger
problem, which is that when
something has always worked a
certain way, sometimes you want
to add a new feature.
You want to add a
new capability.
But then what if someone relied
on it being that exact
specific way that it
was in the past?
KALYAN REDDY: It's kind of
a hard line to walk.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, it is.
We want to make sure that we
continue to make progress and
to enhance the features of
Apps Script, but we also
understand that we don't want
to have something that
previously worked all of
a sudden stop working
because of a change.
So we're trying to ride
that balance.
And if you have more feedback
about a specific change,
always do reach out to us.
We are very conscious of that.
All right.
I think that brings us to
the question and answer
portion of the show.
So we have some folks
on the live Hangout.
Let's go there first and see if
anybody has any questions.
Hello, and welcome to Google
Apps Unscripted.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: Yeah.
Thank you.
I have a question.
ERIC KOLEDA: Sure, go ahead.
It's Harry, right?
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: Yeah.
It's Harry Oosterveen from
the Netherlands.
I'm working on a script to--
well, I have a script moving
messages from Gmail
to Evernote.
And I tried to catch errors
that the users can't use
anyway, like server, it
cannot be reached.
And recently, I think you
mentioned it, it also gives
errors if a library cannot be
found or is not reachable.
Is there a way to catch those
errors, to avoid that people
get emails about it?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes.
KALYAN REDDY: You should be able
to, yeah, just put that
in a [INAUDIBLE] catch, right?
ERIC KOLEDA: So I
think there's--
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: There's
no line number.
Usually if there's an
error, it gives a
line number, you know.
OK, there I should
try and catch it.
But for this one, there's
no line number.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
KALYAN REDDY: You as a
programmer though, you know
when you're making the call to
the library that's missing?
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: Yeah.
KALYAN REDDY: So if
you do, wrap that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Well,
it could be--
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: Is it
not checked before?
ERIC KOLEDA: That's what I'm
wondering, yeah, if perhaps
when the script is first loaded,
when it's trying to
load it for the first time to
begin execution, I wonder if
that point, if it's actually
checking the library.
I guess I always had assumed
that when this kind of weird
library inaccessibility was more
of an edge case, not like
a normal thing people
could run into.
Is it something you're finding
cropping up a lot?
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: I noticed
it popped up a few
times in the past days.
ERIC KOLEDA: I see.
KALYAN REDDY: And is it that
the library was deleted in
each case, or there was
a temporary transient
[INAUDIBLE]?
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: It's a script
that's running every
quarter of an hour.
And usually once every couple
of days it can't find it.
So probably some server
or connection error.
ERIC KOLEDA: Gotcha.
Yeah.
So I guess the first step
usually is like when we have
an error, the first time that
it pops up it's usually that
unknown script error.
And we're like, well,
that's not helpful.
So we try to categorize it,
display a good error message.
But then that helps us figure
out how often it's occurring
and helps people give
us more information.
So I think now that we have a
good error message, you can
help us by telling us that
you're getting these errors on
a regular basis, even though
the script hasn't changed
permissions, and it's
still available.
And then we can kind of dig into
the fact about why is it
that it's popping up when
it shouldn't be.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: It's
not regular.
It's incidental.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
If you're seeing that, then
please open an issue with your
script and the library's key.
And then we'll dig into those
specific instances and see why
they're being flaky
in this case.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: Yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: Great.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: Good.
Thank you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Thank you.
KALYAN REDDY: Anyone else on the
Hangout want to come in?
All right.
ERIC KOLEDA: Feel free to join
in when you have a question.
If not, I think we have
a Google Moderator.
So if you're watching on YouTube
and you don't feel
like joining the Hangout or
don't have a webcam and mic,
on our developers.google.com
page for this event, you can
go in there.
And there's a link to our Google
Moderator where you can
then enter your questions.
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see.
We have a couple of questions
on there now.
So let's take this top
question here.
"Any time line on when
interactive Google Maps will
be part of the APIs, so besides
the staticMaps class?"
ERIC KOLEDA: Gotcha.
So one of our services in Apps
Script is the Maps service,
which provides a bunch
of different
mapping related features.
But one of them is the ability
to generate what are called
Static Maps.
So these are image maps.
They're not draggable.
They're not clickable
or resizable.
They're just an image.
It's useful when you want to
send it in an email or embed
it into a doc, but it doesn't
give you the full power of the
full Maps API that you
would see if you just
did it on the web.
So it is something that the team
has been looking into.
Unfortunately, I can't give
you an exact timeline.
Obviously, timelines in general
are hard to do in
software development.
And we don't want to get your
hopes up unnecessarily.
So do continue to
ask us about it.
And the more information you
can provide about how it's
important to you, the more we
can take that information,
give it to the actual product
and engineering teams, and get
them to take more
action on it.
But do thank you for
checking in.
All right.
I think we have some other
questions on here, too.
So another one here, directed
specifically at me, which is
pretty cool.
Says that I'm the owner of
issue 917 on the issue
tracker, which is
about getting an
array of name ranges.
Is there any progress on that?
And apparently some other
issues that are related.
So this is a good point.
I think it is possible today
to get a named range if you
know the name.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
You can get range by
name, passing the
string of the name.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
But there's no way for you to
discover a la the sidebar that
appears in the UI what all
the name ranges are
that have been defined.
I do not know specifically about
that specific issue,
about where they are, if
they're planning on it.
But I'll revisit that again and
talk to them and see if
there's any progress.
And then we'll update you
again on that issue.
KALYAN REDDY: Cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: And feel free to
actually write a little
message in the issue
tracker there.
And that gets into my email,
and I take a look at those.
Great.
What else do we have Kalyan?
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see.
"Will it be possible
to use chart
services from HTML service?
For instance, use GeoChart
services?
At the moment, Caja prevents me
from using something like
this."
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, so this is
actually kind of along the
same lines as the maps, right?
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
So you want the dynamic
functionality
of the Charts Service.
We do have a Charts bean,
and it outputs a
pre-populated graph.
And you could add filters
to it, so it is
a little bit dynamic--
ERIC KOLEDA: A little
bit dynamic, yeah.
KALYAN REDDY: --in a sense.
But it doesn't have, you know,
like you can roll over and see
fancy things.
You can have the pie chart
that comes up.
ERIC KOLEDA: Most likely.
I know that the visualization
APIs have a ton of options,
ton of options.
KALYAN REDDY: And different
chart types as well.
In GeoChart--
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
that's true.
I think that's the chart we
don't support in the Chart
Service today.
So yeah, I think that's--
we want to allow people to use
the full Google Developer
stack in Apps Script as
much as possible.
With Caja, there are some
limitations today, where
Caja's very, very strict--
that's our sanitization agent
for HTML service--
very strict about what kind
of JavaScript you can use.
And I think some of this
JavaScript doesn't quite
conform correctly today.
And we're working with all those
teams, and we're working
with the Caja team to
kind of help make
this story a lot better.
So something that we're
actively looking into.
KALYAN REDDY: So this falls
into a larger class of
questions, as you mentioned, on
security and using Caja for
sanitization.
And yeah, we're definitely
looking into that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
Unfortunately, no news today
about what you could do, but
it is something that
we're aware of.
All right.
Let's just check in on the
Hangout again, since I know
we've got some people
on there.
Any other questions that
have popped up?
Thoughts?
Cool projects you're
working on?
No?
Oh.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC KOLEDA: Sure.
Go ahead, Harry.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: I
had another issue
that I bumped into.
In my office, we tried to make
clear what groups we have
within Google Apps and
what are the members.
And we have organized a bit
with groups and subgroups.
And on the web interface, if
you look at the groups, you
can see the members.
And also, the groups
that are member of
another group are shown.
But if you go to use the same
function getUser in Google
Apps Script, you only get users
but not the groups that
are a member of the group.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: I
didn't find a way
to get those groups.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I believe
that it is a limitation.
You're talking about using
the Groups App?
KALYAN REDDY: So this is
not the domain group?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
There's two different ways
to access groups
in Google Apps Script.
One is with the domain services,
and one is with the
group services.
The domain services, you need
to be a domain admin.
And it allows you to access your
domain's groups, and it
gives you a more complete
set of information.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: OK.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So if you're a domain admin
and if these are domain
groups, that could
be an interesting
thing to look into.
Because I think instead of
giving you user objects that
correspond to users, like the
Groups App does, it gives you
a list of email addresses that
could be another group or
could be an individual.
KALYAN REDDY: And
you'll actually
recursively drill into that.
That's one of the recent issues
that we fixed where
there was a problem when you
recursively said, is this
email a group or a user?
And then go into, is
this sub-list of
emails a user or a group?
But we fixed that.
And yeah, you could enumerate
each email.
And if that email is an
expansion for more email
addresses, if it's a group,
then you can enumerate all
those until you have all of the
user lists, if you are a
domain admin.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: Yeah, so it's
a domain service that
they have to explore further.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: OK.
But you did point out that is
a limitation of the Groups
App, which is the one for
accessing all Google Groups,
that it only returns concrete
individuals, not groups that
are then members
of that group.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: Right.
Thank you.
That's helpful.
ERIC KOLEDA: No problem.
Anybody else in the Hangout,
feel free to chime in.
And we'll just keep rolling with
the Moderator for now.
So the next one here is--
KALYAN REDDY: Someone
on the Hangout?
ERIC KOLEDA: Do we have a
question on the Hangout?
We do.
Hey.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, go ahead.
ERIC KOLEDA: We can't
hear you.
We are getting some sign
language, though.
KALYAN REDDY: One second.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, he's pointing
to the chat.
Oh, I see.
KALYAN REDDY: Oh, there's
some chat questions.
ERIC KOLEDA: There's some
chat questions, yeah.
Unfortunately, we can't get
the chat here in the room,
only in our studio.
So we'll have our producer
relay some of the chat
questions to us.
KALYAN REDDY: And we'll relay
that to everyone else.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes, we will
work on enabling
better chat in the future.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: But we
could read the chat.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, that's right.
At least Harry has it.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: It's a bit too
long to read it for you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Ah, OK.
Well, Harry, can you
do us a favor and
summarize the chat question?
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: There's
a lot of code in it.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, OK.
KALYAN REDDY: I see.
HARRY OOSTERVEEN: I
have to scroll up.
I have an Apps Script that lets
users insert a link to a
Google Drive file.
But why is the padding around
select panel so big?
Setting the width and height
doesn't seem to alter anything
unless I display browser to
the message box, then the
panel stays open.
And if I click Cancel,
the panel stays open.
The code is-- and I'm not
going to read that.
ERIC KOLEDA: OK.
So whenever there's a question
that involves us looking at
code or going over something,
trying it out, it's probably a
better way for us to handle
that question
on the issue tracker.
Obviously, here in a studio,
we're not at our best for
debugging code on the spot.
So do open an issue tracker
item if there isn't one.
And if there is one--
KALYAN REDDY: If there is an
issue that you determine with
App Script.
Otherwise, you know, on Stack
Overflow, it's another great
place to answer.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's a perfectly
good point.
If you're trying to figure
out how to do
something, Stack Overflow.
If you found an actual
problem in Apps
Script, the issue tracker.
Excellent point, Kalyan.
So unfortunately, I'm not
familiar with the exact
problem that was described.
But we can definitely take a
look at it once it's either on
one of those two forums.
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see.
We've got about five
minutes here.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
We've got a couple
minutes left.
And we actually have
a couple other
questions on the Moderator.
So one was menu items acting as
anchors for the redirect,
similar to the way that in
Sheets, if you click on some
menu items, it pops open a help
page or redirects you to
a help page.
I think we found out that that's
not going to be able to
be possible.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, I think you
can't directly say, you
know, [? menuitem.redirect ?]
something.
We don't have that
functionality.
But an alternative could be,
if it's a simple help page,
then you can create that as an
HTML service page and then
show that whenever someone
clicks the menu.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, so like when
you were in a spreadsheet
and you have a menu item, you
can't redirect that whole tab
or that whole window, right?
You can pop up a dialogue and
then show your own content in
that dialogue.
And one of the things you can do
in that dialogue is show an
anchor that someone could click
that could then open a
new tab, where they can then
see some external content.
So there are some options.
It's probably not exactly what
you were looking for, but
unfortunately, that's
what we have today.
There is usability and security
concerns when a
script can redirect a user
without them really being
aware of it.
So that's why it's
not possible.
KALYAN REDDY: It's a tradeoff.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see.
The last question that we had on
the moderator is, "Can you
add a working example of how
to use the GmailAttachment
class in combination with
.getSize method?" You know, we
just revamped a lot of our
reference documentation and
added a lot of sample code where
there wasn't any before.
So I'm not particularly
familiar with this
GmailAttachment class.
But if there isn't a code
sample there, then we'll
definitely look at
adding that.
ERIC KOLEDA: I remember when
.getSize was added.
And it had something to do with
that sometimes people
just wanted to know the size
of their attachment without
actually fetching the content.
And so it was a way to be more
efficient on our side.
Rather than have you download
all the bytes and then count
them, we provided a .getSize
method that just
tells you the number.
And it's a little more efficient
on everybody.
So that's what .getSize does.
I don't know if there's anything
specifically hard or
difficult about using it.
It should just work as
if it was any other
part of Apps Script.
But if you do run into an issue,
Stack Overflow would be
a good place to ask.
And there's one more that just
phased in as we were talking,
which is about transferring the
ownership of a file from
Apps Script to another user.
Do not think that is
possible today.
So we have the Docs list service
that allows you to
access things in your
Google Drive.
But I don't believe it allows
for determining
or setting the owner.
Am I right on that?
KALYAN REDDY: I think so.
I think you are.
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, that
would be the place
where it would be.
And I do not believe it's one
of the features there.
We do know that ownership
transfer is a big thing,
especially within organizations
where employees
move and you want to make
sure that their
documents don't all disappear.
I know there are ways built
into the Google Apps for
Business administrative
paddles that
allow you to do various--
like transfer all the ownership
for all this user's
documents when you're disabling
their account.
So if it's that use case,
there are some product
features that will help you.
In Apps Script, I don't
think that's a
possibility today, though.
All right.
Well, I think we're just
about out of time.
We want to make sure we leave
time for you guys to get over
to our next Google Developer
Live episode, hosted by Arun
in London, about Script
It! with AdSense.
Head on over.
You can find that link to that
broadcast on GoogleDevelopers
.google.com/live.
And it should be the
first one there.
KALYAN REDDY: And it's the next
live event upcoming on
the Google Developers channel
on YouTube as well.
ERIC KOLEDA: Awesome.
So that's it for us today.
Thank you for joining live.
Thanks for the questions
on the Moderator.
And we'll see you again next
month for another episode.
KALYAN REDDY: See you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Bye bye.